mind your decisions i'm preshtalwalkar
a father said to his son two years ago
i was three times as old as you but in
fourteen years i shall be only twice as
old as you
what were the ages of each this comes
from an 1876
mit entrance exam so presumably
this was a challenging question for that
time period
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try
when you're ready keep watching to learn
how to solve this problem
suppose the father's age is f and the
son's age is
s the father says that two years ago
i was three times as old as you two
years ago
their ages would be f minus two and s
minus two
at that time the father would be three
times as old as the sun
so f minus two will be equal to three
multiplied by the sun's age at the time
which is
s minus 2. we'll put this equation to
the side
the father then says but in 14 years i
shall be only twice as old as you
in 14 years the father will be f plus 14
and the sun will be s plus 14.
at that time the father's age will be
twice that of the sun
thus f plus 14 is equal to twice the
quantity
s 14. we now have a system
of two equations in two variables we'll
first distribute
in each equation then we will subtract
the second equation
from the first the variable f cancels
out
we have 16 is equal to negative s plus
34.
we can solve this equation for the sun's
age
the sun's age will be 18. we can then
substitute into the first equation
we can then solve for the variable f
f will be equal to 50.
thus the father is 50 years old and the
sun is 18 years old
and that's the answer thanks for making
us one of the best communities on
youtube
see you next episode of mind your
decisions where we solve the world's
problems
one video at a time
you